الان من رام الله مدير مكتب الجزيره وليد
العمري صباح الخير وليد اذا المؤتمر
الصحفي الذي عقده نتنياهو بلا شك كان له
اصداء الى جانب هذا القرار بالاجتماع
ل اجتماع مجلس الحرب ضعنا في صوره
التوقعات والاصد
تفضل المؤتمر الذي عقده نتنياهو كان له
اصداء لان وزير الدفاع جلنت والوزير في
مجلس الحرب بن جان رفضا الظهور الى جانبه
في هذا المؤتمر وهو ما عكس عمق حاله عدم
الثقه بين الجانبين لان جلنت وانس يشتبهان
بان نتنياهو انما يسخر هذه المؤتمرات من
اجل خدمه مكاسبه السياسيه الحزبيه لتعزيز
وتثبيت توليفته اليمينيه المتطرفه تصريحات
نتنياهو التي جاءت في هذا المؤتمر الليله
الماضيه هي كانت تكرار لتصريحاته الكثيره
السابقه وابرزها بانه لن يوقف الحرب وانه
سيواصل حتى تحقق اهدافها التي عاد ولخصها
بالقضاء على حماس واعاده من اسماهم
بالمخطوبه قطاع غزه او ان لا يشكل قطاع
غزه مستقبلا اي خطر امني على اسرائيل لكن
الابرز في هذه التصريحات كان الامران
الاول انه تحدث عن محور
فيلادلفيا
بالبوابه الجنوبيه وهو المقصود به الشريط
الحدودي بين قطاع غزه ومصر والذي قال انه
يجب ان يبكون تحت السيطره الاسرائيليه هذا
الموضوع قبل ايام كان الجيش الاسرائيلي
يحاول ان يتعمق به لكنه وصل الى خلاف مع
مصر وبعد 900 متر او اوقف قواته في
الناحيه الشرقيه ولم يواصل والتصريحات
الاسرائيليه كثيره بهذا الخصوص وكان
ابرزها واخرها ما ادلى به وزير الدفاع
الاسبق ليبرمان زعيم حزب اسرائيل بيتينو
الذي قال صباح هذا اليوم ان على اسرائيل
تدميره بالكامل اي تدمير التحصينات حوله
والاس واتاحه المجال لسكان قطاع غزه قد
يفر الى سيناء المصريه وهو يعيد الى ذلك
نذر خطه تهجير اسرائيليه مبيته بخصوص
اعداد كبيره من سكان القطاع الامر الثاني
الذي تحدث عنه نتنياهو ان الحرب ستتواصل
وعلى نطاق واسع وهذا ينسجم مع الانباء
التي جاءت في الساعات الاخيره من ان الجيش
الاسرائيلي انما يوسع من نطاق عمليته
العسكريه البريه في جنوبي قطاع غزه تحديدا
في منطقه خانيونس التي كان قد عزز قواته
فيها باليومين الاخيرين بلواء سابع لكن
بما يتعلق وشمالي القطاع فالان باء التي
تتناقلها المصادر الاعلاميه الاسرائيليه
عن المصادر العسكريه الا اسرائيليه بان
المخطط هو بان تبدا هذه القوات بالخروج من
المناطق الماهوله التي دمرتها وقتلت
سكانها والبقاء داخل قطاع غزه ومجلس الحرب
الذي سيجتمع هذا اليوم سيبحث ثلاثه امور
بالاضافه لمساله استعاده الاسرى
والمحتجزين واحتمال ان يكون هناك تحرك ما
مثل ما قال نتنياهو ان هناك تحرك في هذه
القضيه ولكن لا يشكل اختراقا الموضوعان
الاخران هما يتعلقان اولا بمساله احتماء
الترتيبات للمرحله الثالثه التي يسميها
الاسرائيليون الانتقال الى حرب استنزاف
طويله والموضوع الاخر هو احتمال السماح
لسكان شمالي القطاع الذين نزحوا الى جنوبه
بالعوده الى هذه المناطق بشكل يكون مضبوط
اسرائيليا بالنسبه لما ذكر بالامس في نت
ما اعلنه نتنياهو بخصوص اليوم التالي
نتنياهو كان قد او او عزه لقوات الجيش
والامن الاسرائيلي بالبحث عما اوصفها
ممثلين لعشائر وحمولات في قطاع غزه كي
تستلم اداره مناطقها بمعنى ان لا تكون
هناك سلطه اداريه مركزيه في قطاع غزه
وانما تكون هناك ادارات مكونه من عشائر
او حمائل في انحاء القطاع لكن واضح بان
هذا لن يكلل بالنجاح بسبب الاوضاع
الموجوده هناك و عاد وقال بانه لا يريد ان
تك يكون قطاع غزه لا حماس ستان ولا فتح
ستان حسب تعبيره بمعنى ان لا يكون تابعا
للفصائل الفلسطينيه سواء كانت الدين
الاسلاميه او الوطنيه هذا الوضع المتواصل
في قطاع غزه يشير تشير المعلومات الوارده
الى ان المعارك في شمالي القطاع هي على
هيئه كر وفر وحرب عصابات هناك وفق
الاسرائيليين انفسهم لكنها تتركز بشكل خاص
في حي الدرج والتفاح وايضا منطقه جباليا
المعارك الضاريه القويه هي في منطقه خان
يونس على وجه الخصوص يقول الجيش
الاسرائيلي انه حقق تقدما تقدما بطيئا لكن
قواته الكبيره تعمل وتتحرك فيها وانها
ضبطت مقاره قياديه واستخبارات لكتائب
القسام وانها استولت على انفاق وانها
تحارب فوق الارض وتحت الارض لكن اللافت في
ذلك كله بان كل هذا التصعيد سواء باللهجه
الاسرائيليه او الميدانيه في قطاع غزه هو
يسبق وصول وزير الخارجيه الامريكيه بلينكن
المفترض ان يصل نهايه هذا الاسبوع الى
اسرائيل في زياره خامسه بعد ان كان قد
صادق على تزويدها بكميات كبيره من القذائف
الذكيه الجديده وياتي اليها كتعبير اضافي
عن الدعم ولكن بالاساس لبحث ملفين الاول
يتعلق بمحاوله تعزيز ما يوصف بالهدنيا
وادخال مساعدات او مضاعفتها لقطاع غزه
لانها تراجعت وتضاءلت كثيرا واصبح الامر
فيه نوع من الاحراج للامريكيين انفسهم
والموضوع الثاني يتعلق بقضيه اعاده محاوله
بحث ما يصفه الامريكيون باليوم التالي
للحرب من سيتسلم السلطات هناك هذا الموضوع
محل خلاف داخل الحكومه الاسرائيليه نفسها
بين نتنياهو وجنس وايضا بين داخل الطاقم
الوزاري الامني السياسي المصغر الكبير حيث
ان هناك من يلمح وهو ما فعله وزير الماليه
سموتريتش زعيم الصهيونيه الدينيه الذي قال
بان قطاع غزه يجب ان يبقى تحت السيطره
الاسرائيليه لاطول مده ممكنه وهو ما عاد
يحمل نذر احتمال ان هناك في هذه الحكومه
من يسعى لاعاده اقامه مستوطنات في قلب
قطاع غزه بعد ان يكون قد تسبب بتهج جير
قصري لمئات الالاف من سكان القطاع او على
الاقل تحويل اجزاء منه تحديدا في شماله
الى مناطق غير صالحه للحياه القوات
الاسرائيليه المحتشد في قطاع غزه تشير الى
ما كان وزير الدفاع الاسرائيلي قد اعلنه
وهو ان الثقل الان او المجهود الحربي كما
قال يتركز بالاساس على قطاع غزه ولكن على
منطقه خان يونس تحديدا التي يرى فيها
الاسرائيلي انها قد تكون المعركه الفاصله
التي قد يتجهون بعدها نحو تحقيق اهدافهم
التي تشير كافه التقديرات في اسرائيل لدى
الخبراء ولدى العسكريين السابقين
والعالمين بمواطن الامور انهم وان حققوا
انجازات تكتيكيه لكنهم حتى الان لم يحققوا
تقدما فعليا نحو تحقيقها تصريحات نتنياهو
بالامس ايضا كانت موجهه الى حزب الله في
لبنان وتحدث عن ان اسرائيل تحارب على عده
جبهات قال قطاع غزه والضفه الغربيه ولبنان
وسوريا هذهه الجبهه ايضا كانت قد شهدت
سواء على صعيد التصريحات الاسرائيليه او
على الصعيد الميداني تصعيدا خلال ال 24
ساعه الاخيره شمل ايضا المناطق السوريه
حيث كان هناك قصف ل مطار حلب وقبله مطار
دمشق وقصف لعده مواقع للجيش السوري على
جانب خط وقف اطلاق النار في الجولان وقصف
على طول الحدود داخل خ لبنان
تحديدا في قريه كفر كلا التي قال الجيش
الاسرائيلي انه احبط ثلاث خلايا كانت
تحاول اطلاق النار او التسلل الى داخل
اسرائيل بالاضافه لمسيرتي في مزارع شبعه
اشكرك جزيلا وليد العمري مدير مكتب
الجزيره على كل هذه التفاصيل المهم